hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to
emergency anime club episode 4 this time
we'll be talking about our top ten
favorite anime characters good and bad I
feel like a lot of anime top list
usually only lists the good characters
but some of my favorite characters are
the evil ones or at least the ones that
are written really well maybe that would
make an excellent topic for next week's
anime club forever evil speaking of
which you guys have been making some
awesome anime club suggestions so please
keep it up right now let's give a high
five to last week's giveaway winners
commander Sloan you win the crunchyroll
anime figure and Fanny Martin you get to
pick a future anime club topic I'll be
reaching out to both you guys on your
channels just for contact info this week
I'm giving away a $20 Amazon gift card
and PayPal equivalent to international
people be sure to subscribe to
participate this is always more fun with
friends so let's get started top 10
anime characters number 10 guts from
berserk easily one of the best swordsmen
ever the lone warrior archetype has
always been a favorite of mine the story
of his childhood has developed in this
really incredible way and watching him
become a better fighter you know largely
without the aid of magic is really cool
I really do feel like it's hard for non
magical anime characters to compete with
their counterparts but this story is
just so compelling I had to put him on
the list number 9 Alucard from Helsing
he's Dracula and my all-time favorite
vampire stories are always Dracula
stories but his fights are so much fun
especially with the addition of his
taunts Plus you would not expect Dracula
to be fighting with guns I also have to
say I'm a big fan of his style the
Victorian outfit you know complete with
the cowboy duster coat is really cool
number 8 spike Spiegel and Cowboy Bebop
he's one of the best and war characters
ever I'm a really big fan of the crime
genre and he has this really casual
nature that mislead you into thinking
he's soft but he's actually one of the
more violent characters on my list I
have to say my favorite spike episode of
bebop is definitely Ballad of fallen
angels number 7 Levi from attack on
Titan yes he's overpowered but he is the
best fighter on the best new anime
series in the world right now he's
really like the unsung hero of Titan at
least inside the show the fandom
definitely does give him the credit he
deserves though I'm really interested to
see if they depower him in season 2
although to be fair it does seem like
everyone is turning into a human form
Titan so they might not have to depower
him number 6 Totoro from Totoro
he's so ubiquitous around the world that
he became the
for studio ghibli so you could argue
that he is so awesome he has to be in
every movie they make at least in the
logo I'm sure if you looked hard enough
you could probably find him drawn into a
background frame and all of the
subsequent films he's been in he's like
the r2d2 of anime the world's best
mascot number five career pika from
hunter x hunter the red eyes of
vengeance
I love how powerful that nen abilities
made the character and how they added
all those restrictions to keep it from
getting ridiculous
you know a lot human form Titans the
Phantom true part is probably the best
one to revisit if you're looking to get
back into the series number four Mikasa
from attack on Titan Eren might be the
real protagonist for the series but
Mikasa is the most identifiable unless
you count the Titans in my mind she's
the backbone of the ensemble she has to
protect the person that has to protect
everyone the marketing materials and the
phantom though is just a little bit
misleading
I actually thought she was the
protagonist of the series when I first
started watching number 3 lust from
Brotherhood favorite bad girl ever I
definitely have a bias towards bad girls
she is the benefit of being a major
character for a giant chunk of the
series and it was so much fun watching
her be downright evil then turn away
from her mission and try to become human
just so she could die permanently she is
smoking hot and I have to say one of her
hottest scenes was definitely the last
scene also my favorite scene of hers
number 2 paprika she's like the Scarlett
Johansson character from her living in
the world of Christopher Nolan's
inception and the Matrix trilogy she's
the most epic digital avatar in all of
anime so it's only natural that people's
minds manifest her to lead them through
the digital dream world you could also
argue that because the dream in reality
worlds begin to merge she's one of the
most powerful anime characters if I ever
got stuck in the dream world
I would definitely manifest her to be my
spirit guide and my number one favorite
anime character no surprise here Edward
Elric from Brotherhood I should really
include Alphonse on the list because the
brothers really need to be taken as a
duo if it weren't for the two of them I
don't think the Brotherhood would have
been one of the biggest anime shows on
the planet for the last decade the
reason why Edward and said brother are
my favorites are because their
characters can swing so easily from
funny to sad from warriors to scientists
and from normal kids to tragic heroes as
with all lists there are always a
billion anime characters you could put
on them so let me know weigh your
favorites in the comments below
I'm definitely biased towards new
characters I'm always looking for
awesome anime characters to kind of
knock the old favorites off the list and
attack on Titan has actually been one
series that's done that so far like I
said earlier forever evil is gonna be
the topic of next week's anime club I
don't know exactly how it's gonna go but
it's gonna be a lot of fun be sure to
subscribe to get that video as always
please leave your suggestions for other
future anime club topics right now click
here for last week's anime club video
and click here for my Walking Dead
countdown it's coming back and it's
gonna be a lot of fun thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives